[Music]
let's go to
liz in charleston south carolina hey liz
what's going on
hi dr john thank you so much for taking
my call hey thank you for giving me a
shout what's going on
um i was calling to ask
how do i have the conversation
with my husband okay do me a favor
before you
before you go two things talk directly
in the phone
and i can already hear
there's something really close to the
surface are you okay
yeah take a deep deep breath for me
and just hold it
and now let it out
is where you're calling from safe yes
cool i promise to be safe too and i will
only
make fun of ben in the control room
that's it you got it okay all right cool
okay so how do you have the conversation
and that's um keep going
that i am a survivor of sex trafficking
[Music]
um
i just i'm
so are you married and your husband
doesn't know correct okay
um how long have you been married
um a little under a year
how long did y'all date before um
since 2018 summer of 2018. i see all
been together for a while how old are
you
yeah um i'm 28. 28.
okay you like this guy
yes a lot is he super good looking
yes he is for rick for real are you just
saying that
sometimes you talk to somebody like hey
is that guy your husband looking and
she's like oh my gosh
yes and you see him you're like nope no
he's not right
he for real is
and how did you meet him um
we go to the gym together oh gross
you're at the gym just flexing and he
was like doing tricep extensions looking
at you
yeah pretty well hey totally inside
conversation i know we're in the middle
of a heavy thing
how how do you
how do you how do you meet somebody at a
gym how does that happen
um like has who made the first move
this is one of life's great mysteries to
me
um inadvertently me i um
that's so ridiculous liz i said i wasn't
gonna laugh at you but i lied
what do you mean inadvertently
um i thought he was we were leaving the
gym at the same time
and i thought he was asking me for my
phone number but he was actually talking
to the person behind me
um that's the most preposterous so you
just walked up to this super hot guy
leaving a gym and you handed him your
number and you're like oh
you're just asking for yeah he was
actually talking to the guy behind him
because they were going to work out
together
listen liz that may be one of the
greatest moves i've ever heard of
i've heard of crazy moves that's legit
i've never heard of that one
where you just walked up to a stranger
and you're like oh hey um
you were just asking for my number here
it is that's a baller move
and then he clearly was like okay
yeah and then he called you or texted
you or whatever
yeah ladies and gentlemen
that's how the gym date is is born
and that could have gone sideways but it
didn't so now ended up with a marriage
all right okay thank you for solving
life's great mystery i will now give you
free advice on whatever your challenges
are how about that it's a good trade
okay thank you so you're with this guy
let's reverse engineer this
you've been with him for a couple years
he's awesome he's wonderful
you care about him you love him you
married him you
are building a life with him and you've
got this
big deep dark hidden past
right tell me about what happened in the
past
um i was in a
relationship with someone for four years
um that was abusive in
every single way you could think of
um
and it just like
tiny little things just kept escalating
and escalating and tell me what that
means
tell me what that means um
it it means
like stuff
you i guess the way he like introduced
this
to me was that he was like well i just
want
to have a threesome and of course like
being in a relationship and wanting to
um make your partner happy that's
kind of how that started and then so
slowly your boundaries just got pushed
further
and further in little increments right
yeah and before i knew it he
was he reached out to
an escort service and started pimping me
out
through their service
and ultimately how were you able to
transition out of that
um i ran away
i i mean like
he had told me that the only way i was
ever going to get out
is that if we like essentially both
he was going to like take him kill me
and then take himself out
sure
and so for uh for the the person
listening
wondering how does this happen i would
and
and it's easy to think i would just do
this or i would
i would just um what i'll let you know
is there are power dynamics at play in
these situations there is
really challenging
really tough psychological
things that happen physical things that
happen when you're in a highly abusive
and toxic relationship
and you just said it perfectly suddenly
you wake up and one day you
highly uncomfortable with the next step
but it will keep you safe today
and then you become highly uncomfortable
the next step but
nobody's going to get hit and
yeah it's easy to say hey i'll just call
so-and-so but
not if somebody's got your cell phone
right or they're paying for your bill or
it's not one of those things that you
just wake up one day and you're flipping
through netflix and someone's like hey i
got an idea it's not how it works right
and so i want everyone listening to this
to understand
the physiological the psychological the
biological
pathway the way this works is not a
simple oh my gosh just
it's not right
and then suddenly yeah you find yourself
under water and that water comes up
around you and you're chained to the
floor and all of a sudden you're
drowning
right and you ran away tell me about
what that looked like
um i
knew he had to be in
another city about two hours away from
where we were living
so that i had about a five to six hour
window
to pack up my dogs and all
anything i could fit in my car and take
with me
um so i i did i dropped
my dogs off at a hotel
and told them what was going on
that i was running away from an abusive
relationship and
i just needed a place to drop my dogs
off while i
tried to get as much of my things out of
my house as i could
can we pause right there just again for
the listener
if you are have never been trapped in an
abusive or traumatic relationship
often i've seen people who will hold
their dog or their cat
in a way that is a it's like holding a
life raft
right these weren't just your dogs these
were your last
last thread connected to reality
right yeah this is the only safe thing
you've got so
again i'm trying to i'm trying to play
by play this for the listener
um man you think like just leave your
dogs and run man that's all i got
right yeah and when you're in a fire you
hang on to that teddy bear with all you
got
right so okay so you've dropped your
dogs off you run away
where did you go um
i stayed at the hotel long enough
to get my things i actually broke into a
storage
facility um and
wound up calling the owner once i got a
hold of them because i lived in the
middle of nowhere and they don't just
like
sit at the facilities um
and was like hey this is what i'm doing
i'll
pay you when i can um
but i knew if i
left my dogs he would find a way to like
hold hold that over me and of course
know that i'd be protective of them and
threaten to hurt them
and so fast forward
did you end up going to the police did
you end up going to a care shelter
how did you get into a place where you
started dating again you started going
to the gym again you started like
tell me about that journey yeah i um
i moved back home to my parents um
did you talk to them about all this uh
i talked to them about the abuse but
i've never
actually told them the extent of it okay
um
i don't i don't know like part of me
doesn't want to put that on them
even though like you know they're my
parents and that's what they're there
for
but i i guess it's the same thing with
like
now feeling the need to tell my husband
like i don't want to keep
this like huge secret from him but at
the same time like how do i dump
something that big on him or anyone i
care about because they
first and foremost man i'm so sorry
you've got one beautiful precious
life and somebody stole a big chunk of
yours and i'm sorry
and i know that doesn't make it go away
i know that doesn't make it
better but right now when you're just
sitting there in a pool and don't have
any water in it and you just got your
face in your hands i want you to know
i'm sitting there right next to you
sucks i hate that
i hate that
so the demon of abuse
the reason abuse is so evil besides the
the power dynamics and the actual pain
that
that abuse causes is it weaponizes the
only thing that makes us whole
that makes us people which is
relationships
the only thing that makes us able to
function our hearts literally beat right
to make it right and your brain
is going to do everything it can to
protect you from that ever happening
again
right and so it's going to create all
universes for you that you live in and
can navigate
and it's going to really build a nice
big concrete bunker around what happened
and drop into the ocean and only you
know it's there
except everyone around you know
something's there they just don't have
any clue as to what it is
right yeah and so
at some point sooner rather than later
you're gonna have to choose wholeness
and connection over secrets
you know that right yeah it sounds like
you're there
have you ever told this to anybody have
you ever met with a counselor or a
trauma psychologist have you ever worked
through
what actually happened um i tried to
meet with a counselor one time and i
don't know
i don't know if i just didn't click with
her or what
hey i'm gonna stop you right there okay
is the third person you've told me about
that's not your abuser
and it's the third apology you've made
for your interaction with that person
and a hallmark of an abused person is
somebody who thinks every relational
inconsistency every relational issue is
their fault they screwed something up
if so if nothing else you get from this
phone call is
you hang up the phone and for the rest
of your life you stand six inches taller
you got me
yeah you're a strong brilliant beautiful
brave woman
period okay
okay so it may be that you didn't click
maybe the counselor sucked maybe this is
a big like if you haven't worked with
people who do
trauma they don't you know you take
special classes for this in grad school
right this isn't just part of the
curriculum
right um and it may be
that you don't want to burden your
parents
but it may be like they're the only ones
that can walk alongside you
maybe you don't want to burden your
husband that's what he signed up for
now this is big right he didn't know
these secrets are coming but he said for
better or worse
sickness and health right
so you went and saw a counselor it
what was her response
um i'm just shaking my head here because
i cannot feel it coming
she pretty much told me that i sounded
um
like i was over the situation and
um that i was
that i was fine like um so one day
you don't have any more video games to
play just
reach out to the whatever licensing
board is in that community or that state
and file on her or him
for being a terrible unethical counselor
because that person doesn't have the
right to
see any more people okay
because that person is going to hurt
other people
good sounds like you're good man shake
it off all right high five
wow are you over it now
no i was being sarcastic
um i know clearly oh
man so here so here's what you've got
ahead of you
you've got a number of
um challenging sessions with a trauma
therapist
whether that's emdr whether that's um
more adult centered trauma-focused
cognitive behavioral therapy whatever
that looks like relational therapy
you've got some work to do here okay
and my promise is the theft of your life
won't come back those years that were
stolen from you
um the innocence that was taken from you
that
won't those will be there those happen
but what can happen
think of it this way you know those
bricks that are in your backpack now
that you carry into every relationship
every room and even when you're just
peacefully laying there on the couch
watching tv sometimes your heart will
just
spin up on you and you'll or you'll see
some guy in a mall who reminds you of
some way somebody looked at you
whatever the thing is i want you to know
those bricks that you're carrying around
that
that literally bend you over and and
lean you down like right they make you
crouch over because you're so exhausted
and every relationship you go into you
go in looking up at it right you go in
apologetically i'm so sorry i didn't
mean to i'm so old
it's probably me you can take those
bricks out
and you're gonna stand six inches taller
and here's the beautiful part you can
redeem that stuff
the bricks become the
pathway that you walk on and equally as
important
it becomes the pathway your kids walk on
your neighbors walk on
making meaning of this thing grieving it
and healing from it
and i'm telling you right now you can
heal you can't
grieve it hard and you can't heal but
you've got to have other people in your
life
right yeah
so my recommendation on this
is yes you've got to tell your husband
does he know you're in
a really abusive relationship in the
past yes
okay to what extent
um he
knows that my ex was um physically
abusive as far as hitting me
um i have a burn mark on my arm
um that he knows he he did that um
he knows that he raped me
[Music]
um so he knows this isn't like an
evil guy by the way is this guy in jail
oh yeah uh he's dead
okay that's a that's that's another call
liz
um yeah hey and here's another weird
thing that most people don't know
that probably messed you up didn't it it
did
yep people think that oh that guy who is
evil and hurt me
is dead hooray that's not how that works
either right there's a part of you that
is that's a whole other trauma right
yeah
so here's what you i'm not gonna say to
your husband
you do but that's not the point of this
call you owe this to you
i want you to sleep all night
and i want you to laugh from your guts
and i want you not to have to scan every
room for who's coming next for liz
and that's what healing looks like okay
i want you to be able to eat a whole
meal i want you to be able to your
husband to say some freaky thing
and be like hey you want to try this in
the bed and i don't want every alarm you
have to go off
i want you to be able to go all right
weirdo you know what i mean
i want you to be able to engage him in
that way and i know you do too
and so the healing starts
here's the thing you've told him more
than you think you have
right now you feel this big giant deep
dark secret and it is it's a big secret
right and he's gonna be understandably
shaken to his core right yeah
he is going to be he's going to be
frustrated he's probably going to say
why didn't you tell me why'd you lie to
me
all that stuff is fair and
he already knows a big chunk of it
he knows that you stared evil in the eye
he just doesn't know how far evil
dragged you
down the road right and so here's my
recommendation my recommendation is
you let him know
hey i'm gonna go do some hard trauma
work
i have to right
if you look at the aces a c e s
it's a trauma scale one to ten my guess
is you are
really high on that asus score it's a
score out of 10. you can get online and
take just uh
we'll link one of the show notes you can
get online and get the ace of scores
and nadine burke harris dr harris out of
i think she's out of san francisco
really remarkable physician and
researcher but it's really
revolutionized trauma response
it's 10 questions it's simple and
what i'll tell you is if you have four
of the 10
your likelihood of cancer and heart
disease and stroke
is exponentially higher and then you go
five so we're not just talking about hey
i'm in a bad mood
talking about your body starts to
dissolve itself right and then you get
up to six seven eight so
here's what i'm telling you that i want
you to treat this like a medical
condition
you've got because it is you've got it
is a heart issue it's a it's a soul
issue but it's a medical
condition i want you to let your husband
know
hey i told you i was in an abusive
relationship a dark ugly messy one
there's more to it
that i've just gotta work through and i
am not in a place where i can talk to
you about it i
promise i will and i promise you i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do the hard work to
heal
and at some point y'all will be in
couples therapy together too as y'all
walk through this
but this is a big enough deal that i
want you to have some healing
and strategies under your belt
some breathing techniques some
relational techniques some connection
techniques
before you lay this out and i think it
would be healthy to have a
another counselor another person in the
room with you whether it's a therapist a
psychologist or the like
i have been in these rooms when a wife
finally tells a husband something
nothing this this serious this this this
um traumatic but some pretty tough stuff
and it's just good to have other people
in the room um
it adds a adds a
right um and there's just a level of
safety in that room
okay so the the truth telling starts
today the truth telling starts this
weekend
with hey you know how evil this was
it's worse all right there's stuff i'm
coming to terms with that i was a part
of that i got dragged through
that i'm still messing with and i've got
to go see somebody all got a budget for
this this is going to be a part of your
life for a season
and i want you to find a good trauma
counselor in your area
okay and be very specific about that
um what a lot of trauma victims like
your experience especially
sex trafficking sexual abuse they become
very very strong
and very very good at being who what
they need to be to be safe in a certain
situation
because you've been in a lot of unsafe
situations fair
yes yeah so your your superpower
is contortionism right um
psychological you can become whatever
you need to be to be safe in a situation
do whatever you got to do to get out of
that room alive
right yeah
now the hard part is learning how to be
vulnerable again
and you just gotta have to get somebody
to walk alongside you
do you promise you'll do that for liz
yes
okay you're at a point where you can't
do this by yourself
and fast forward a year fast forward six
months
you go do some really hard trauma work
some scary
but with a great professional some good
trauma healing
you learn some skills how to take back
control of your body
right and then fast forward to your
husband's in this room and you'll have
this conversation
and you've got a therapist that you
trust in there or two
i've been a part of one there was two of
us in there um
and you have this conversation with your
husband in your heart of hearts
what's he gonna do
hug me and cry exactly right
i think he's going to hug you until you
can't heart so you got to say hey
like i gotta breathe right
yeah sounds like a guy that loves you to
the moon and back
he fell for your stupid hey i thought
you asked for my number line for crying
out loud
right
sounds like you won the lottery with
this guy i want you to love liz as much
as he does
okay okay and i want you to recognize
you're gonna have to learn new skills to
do that
you're a brave woman thanks for being
vulnerable with a million strangers that
you don't know
and walking people through man
reminds me of this old
reminds me of this old um
quote it's attributed to 50 different
people but
be nice to everybody because
behind smiles and behind their eye
crinkles everyone's fighting battles
that you have
no idea they're in war right
i know i butchered that quote but and
you don't know
if the person next to you who had a
rough boyfriend once
you don't know the depths of hell that
she may have traveled
thanks for being brave liz so grateful
you escaped i'm so grateful
that you had people along the way the
hotel owner the people who said
you're safe here pets are safe here
so glad you met a guy who loves you for
who you are so glad you've been brave to
talk to him about your abuse thus far
and you're going to take the next step
and begin a healing journey
good for you good for you good for you
and by the way
if you are married to somebody if you've
been dating somebody who's experienced
deep deep trauma
if they ever have the courage to come
tell you what's going on what happened
man um
the first response is always i love you
in a hug
and that's about it questions come later
discussions come later uh how come
that's all later
the best thing to say in that moment is
nothing
but weep with them sit with them hug
them if that's safe
and don't let go thank you so much for
your call liz